i'm here with the beautiful on the
inside and out my dear friend anthony
perovski
um
now you're gonna show us a delicious
dish that pairs well with our gorgeous
croque signore yes okay i'm obsessed
with leaks and i feel like a lot of
people are intimidated by them because
there's always a lot of sand in between
the layers which throws a lot of people
off but they're relatively inexpensive
and when you know how to treat them
right they're delicious and this recipe
is literally i think it's just like five
ingredients and it's an awesome little
side dish that you can do if you're
having meat if you're having fish if
you're going vegetarian whatever the
situation is so what you want to do is
cut off like the really tough green
parts most of these have been cut off as
long with the root yes and then you just
basically cut them crosswise
or lengthwise crosswise lengthwise
have let's go with halved um and then
you just want to rinse these underwater
like these have been perfectly clean to
get the sand out think of it as like
clams it's exactly yeah it's i you know
what when you're right you're right
and you're right about that right i'm
just i'm just jealous that i didn't come
up with that one because that's actually
really it's very it's true because they
always have sand that comes out anyway
okay we're gonna make a little
vinaigrette that we're gonna pour over
them by
so we have a little bit of olive oil
that's lemon juice and lemon which one
should i start with because building is
important oh not too not for this okay i
feel like it's all just being mixed all
right a bit of salt
not all of it just yeah okay i got
nervous
perfect
um lemon juice lemon juice and zest
and then some dijon the whole thing more
mustard yeah
let's go
and then a bit of perfect got it you got
it son of a
okay and then a little bit of fresh
cracked pepper so we want to mix that up
beautiful yeah it's pretty nicely mixed
there you go give it away just take it
away did you make did you get messy oh i
messed up the blouse
he's gonna kill me you'll be fine and
then you just wanna pour it
and try to like open up the layers so
that it really goes in between so that
with every bite you get a little bit of
that vinegar yeah
open her up
okay
so we have this here i'm going to plop
this into the oven so that's it that's
it that's literally it that's simple so
what you want to do is you roast it for
a bit
how long what temp
like for
400 for 10 minutes no i think a little
longer than that like probably 20ish
minutes or so because you want to break
down that leak you don't want it to turn
into mush but exactly you want it to cut
nicely and then when you take it out um
i grade a bit of parm
and then basically do you have oh
perfect i don't know but i want to get
in here i'm just getting in here
where's my four
oh
[Applause]
nicely
if you got rid of that exterior layer oh
that's still a little hot
they're so good
i don't feel good isn't it so nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this vinaigrette
is perfect too
because i still taste the mustard but i
also still taste the olive oil yes which
on a dish like this olive oil the
sharpness from the
i was about to wipe you with beige
chameleon that would have been a mess
but i'm glad that i but my lipstick has
been all over my face this last two
segments which is the sign of a good
time there you go that's what i always
say
that's three
that's three things my father's gonna
bring up
anthony perovski i have been on several
adventures with you and i just hope they
never end i'm having so much fun
just living my life with and around you
i love you and i love how much joy you
bring to the world i know i've said that
before but i love who you are as a human
being i love you so much
[Music]
dear gem anthony perovski the most
handsome beautiful book i'm not kidding
i have two copies that's how much i love
your book and two copies go to our
website for all these recipes and be
sure to get anthony's latest cookbook
let's do dinner wherever books are sold
[Music]